[Music]
on this thursday night from quebec city
morning mass interrupted the pope
confronted by protesters demanding he
rescind the doctrine of discovery
the story behind the centuries-old edict
and why indigenous communities are
calling for it to be cancelled a quebec
man killed in combat in ukraine really
we miss him his comrades and commander's
message to the canadians family in a
global news exclusive deal or no deal
moscow responds to washington's proposed
prisoner swap to free to americans
funds for your firearms
the price the feds are willing to pay to
buy back banned weapons
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight from quebec city jeff
semple
we are looking inside the notre dame de
quebec the cathedral basilica is
canada's oldest church dating back to
the 17th century where as you can see
pope francis met with local and national
church leaders tonight capping off
another busy day as we enter the final
hours of his historic visit
[Applause]
good evening and thank you for joining
us we are coming to you again tonight
from a rainy quebec city just steps from
that church in the heart of old quebec
on a day that began with morning mass
confronting the scandal of evil
and the body of christ wounded in the
flesh of our indigenous brothers and
sisters
we too have experienced deep dismay
we too feel the burden of failure
the pontiff acknowledged for the first
time on this trip the sexual abuse
inflicted on minors and vulnerable
people and he said the church is on a
new path the ceremony was held at the
basilica of saita and de beaupre on the
outskirts of quebec city in attendance
there canadian prime ministers both past
and present quebec's premier and other
dignitaries but most of the 1400 people
in attendance were representatives of
indigenous communities with residential
school survivors seated in the front
pews
the pope will head north to iqaluit
tomorrow the final stop on his canadian
tour but as the penitential pilgrim
pilgrimage enters its final hours some
say his apologies and his actions so far
have failed to live up to their hopes
and expectations mike armstrong was out
speaking with those crowds who were
outside the church today so mike the
crowd's not quite as big as the
organizers had expected at least but
what did you hear from people about how
the day what the day was like for them
yeah it was very emotional for a lot of
people both inside and outside the
basilica and this is interesting
sometimes for very different reasons
[Music]
they may celebrate mass in every
catholic church in the world but not
like this with the scars left by
residential schools as the focus
and addressed by the pope himself now
they understand because nobody knew
about us carolyn longchap says hearing
it all exposed helps leave the anger
behind
my children my grandchildren
never knew about this
so
i am talking about it now on tv
and i think they're going to be
surprised to hear the
truth
thousands followed the service from
outside the basilica it was also another
spot in quebec city for more people but
not everyone showed up for the same
reason paul dixon turned out on this
date to protest not for the apology no
no no i came here on behalf of once i'm
never going to be here
never going to recover their childhood
days or teenagers
lost in those indian prisons
so-called schools
now the goal of this trip wasn't to put
up big numbers it wasn't about the
crowds it was about residential schools
but it's still being hard not to be
struck by how small the crowds have been
the last papal visit to this city was in
1984 pope john paul held mass for an
estimated 300 thousand people this visit
has been different but so is this pope
he has kind of like shaken the carpet
and like all the dirt is coming out
social worker lorena figueroa came from
toronto she says pope francis's time as
the leader of the church has been
focused on some painful jobs exposing
and repairing some of the church's
mistakes
i can just say like a cleanse
you know what a cleanses and always like
okay so you have a scar a wound you
really hurt yourself you got to clean it
it hurts and it's horrible
now this visit hasn't been about growing
the church or prophesizing it's been
about apologizing so even though the
crowds have been somewhat smaller that
doesn't mean they haven't been important
especially for the people that they've
been supposed to be for yeah all right
mike armstrong with us in quebec city
tonight thanks mike and the pope's
morning mass was interrupted at one
point by indigenous protesters demanding
action on a long-standing issue
[Music]
protesters unveiled a banner that read
rescind the doctrine now that is a
reference to the so-called doctrine of
discovery a 15th century edict that the
church and governments used to justify
their seizure of indigenous lands the
protesters were escorted out of the
church where they continued their
demonstration outside
the prime minister and pontiff are said
to have discussed that centuries-old
edict in their meeting this week and
canada's catholic bishops confirm they
are working with the vatican on a plan
to address that issue nithu garcia has
more on the doctrine's devastating
impact and the growing calls to rescind
it
grand chief herb norwegian says the way
he and his people consume the land's
resources
is still dictated in large part by the
doctrine of discovery
it was a tool that that they used
to take land from
unchristian first nation people the
philosophy was used to legitimize the
colonization of indigenous peoples
around the world dehumanizing exploiting
and subjugating them of their most basic
rights chief norwegian says to this day
it informs canadian and american
government policies the united states
government the whole constitution is
basically based on on the doctrine of
discovery the root of all evil is that
doctrine of discovery
and it has to be rescinded georgina
lightning and her daughter crystal are
raising awareness about the ongoing
implications through a new documentary
called the doctrine of recovery we need
a female
driven story about this doctrine because
you know all that it has done to us no
more pretending our survival depends
upon us caring for our life the film
screened in edmonton monday the same day
the pope failed to address the doctrine
in his apology i hope that he
acknowledges
what has happened
without
you know meaningful acts
to follow through
it will just be all for not elder
claudette commander says even after the
canadian government overtly rejected the
doctrine by passing bill c-15 last year
harmonizing the country's laws with the
u.n declaration on the rights of
indigenous peoples revoking the doctrine
would help eliminate a layer of legal
injustice then the courts will no longer
use this against us whenever we move
forward
to
to plead our inherent rights and she
says the pope has the power to take
action 500 plus years and there was one
pope who made a doctrine of discovery
well let's fast forward to 500 plus
years and while this pope can
make a change he can revoke that
doctrine of discovery rest of the
canadian population need to be behind us
and they need to do everything they can
to support first nations on their road
to recovery
because he says the pope telling a
truthful narrative of the past can
create a more hopeful narrative for the
future nitu garcia global news
and later in the program we'll hear from
a mohawk human rights leader on the
doctrine and the pope's visit
for years now we've been on a campaign
to get the vatican to revoke
the people bulls that make up the
doctrine of discovery and we need the
pope to uh to clarify change history uh
to to to understand that that was unjust
and abused by states
and a reminder that if you or someone
you know who is a residential school
survivor are looking for help you can
call the residential school survivors
and family crisis line at 1-800-721-0066
turning now to other news and we are
learning more tonight about the canadian
killed in ukraine when his unit was
ambushed by a russian tank crystal
gomencing has more on his life legacy
and an exclusive interview with those
who fought alongside him
he was here to make a difference his
humanity goofiness and politeness are
some of the attributes highlighted by
his comrades emile antoine
serwa was killed in action july 18 in
rihorrifka
30 soldiers from his unit were trying to
hold back a russian advance on the
village in eastern ukraine he and three
others were killed while trying to help
a wounded soldier we just took so much
incoming fire it was mortars artillery
tanks shooting at us and everything at
once
so yeah we were expecting
more of us to go that day the village
didn't fall but the deadly mission
resulted in several members terminating
their contracts with ukrainian armed
forces four of my best friends
is died despite the losses
many maintain their resolve
i'm going gonna stay here to the end of
my life or to the end of the war when
global news met up with some of the
soldiers who took part in the mission
they had just held a service for an
american who was killed oscar left the
hospital to attend the memorial talking
about the tragic day with an ivy
catheter still in his left hand they are
heroes
and i love them and i remember them and
they died like soldiers
global affairs canada is aware of cerro
and is working with the family his
remains are currently in nepro and once
canada provides the right documentation
they'll be transported here to key for
small service
and then shipped home in a statement to
global news his mother wrote in part
today emil antoine would surely wish
that the world understood by virtue of
his actions the importance of returning
to more human values i'm sorry that i
could not
save
her son ruslan was one of the men who
went back to the field to retrieve the
quebecer's body as one of the commanding
officers for the international fighters
he says the man they called beaver was
special big handsome soft power you know
kind of yeah and really we miss him
ciroi came to ukraine to join the fight
in march
he was 31 years old
crystal gamansen global news
keith
russia is responding to a u.s proposal
for a prisoner swap to free two
americans basketball star brittany
griner and paul whalen are currently in
custody in russia now the kremlin says
it hasn't agreed to any deal and issued
a warning jennifer johnson reports
wnba star brittany griner testified in a
russian court behind bars explaining she
accidentally put vape cartridges
containing cannabis oil in her luggage
which led to her arrest and imprisonment
five months ago
but i did not intend to smuggle or plan
to smuggle anything into russia back
home the biden administration revealed a
proposed prisoner swap with the kremlin
that deal would free griner and paul
whelan a corporate executive from
michigan serving a 16-year sentence in
russia on espionage charges in exchange
for victor boot a convicted armed
smuggler known as the merchant of death
every single day that paul whelan and
brittany griner remain behind bars
it is
injustice compounded on itself
our goal is to see these cases resolve
just as soon as we can president biden
has signed off on the deal despite
objections from the u.s justice
department boot is serving 25 years in
an illinois prison for conspiring to
kill americans by smuggling weapons to
use against u.s forces while grinder's
case has been in the public eye
wieland's family is anxious to get him
home too and hopeful about this latest
news it shows that the us government is
doing what it can and
also underscores i think the fact that
there are limits to what the us
government can do to bring home
americans secretary of state anthony
blinken says he will discuss the deal
with his russian counterpart sergey
lavrov in the next few days it will be
the first conversation between the two
since russia invaded ukraine i plan to
raise an issue that's a top priority for
us
the release of americans paul whelan and
brittany griner who've been wrongfully
detained
and must be allowed to come home but as
of today a kremlin spokesman says there
is no deal whelan a former marine
remains in prison on what the white
house says are trumped-up charges and
greiner who has pleaded guilty is still
facing 10 years in jail for what she
calls a mistake
jennifer johnson global news washington
a private phone call from canada's top
cop made public
coming up would a senior rcmp officer
testified at the nova scotia massacre
inquiry we are coming to you tonight
from quebec city and we'll be right back
welcome back to quebec city and we are
here covering the latest in pope
francis's canadian tour and we're here
just steps from the notre dame de quebec
basilica cathedral where the pope met
this evening with local church leaders
the last event of this day now heading
into the final day of his canadian tour
we'll have more on his trip in just a
moment but turning now to other news we
are learning more tonight about the
compensation gun owners could receive
under the federal government's mandatory
buyback program a price list has just
been released outlining how much money
owners of banned firearms can expect on
the higher end a swiss arms sg550 could
net more than 6200 dollars while an
ar-15 would be bought for thirteen
hundred dollars
a senior rcmp officer says he believes
there was political interference in the
investigation into the deadly 2020 mass
shooting in nova scotia
chief superintendent chris leather told
a public inquiry in halifax that he
received a private phone call from rcmp
commissioner brenda lucky asking for
details of the killer's firearms other
rcmp members accused lucky of trying to
force them to reveal the weapons make
and model to help the federal liberal
government justify new legislation
so then is it your evidence today that
you are of the impression there was
political interference that's my
impression
the mass casualty commission will
release its finding in a final report
this november
the demands to change the game ahead
survivors speak out on hockey canada's
history of abuse
we're back from quebec city in just a
moment
reaction is pouring in from the hockey
world following this week's shocking
testimony by top hockey canada
executives on parliament hill abigail
beeman reports
my hope is that this is more like a me
too moment greg gilhooley is a survivor
of convicted sex offender and former
hockey coach graham james
he's one of the nine recipients of
hockey canada settlements totaling 7.6
million dollars the vast majority
connected to james he believes the
organization's maintenance of a fund for
victims separate from insurance is a
good thing but says it dropped the ball
closing the investigation into the
alleged 2018 sexual assault when the
victim didn't want to participate
further we still somehow find a way to
investigate a murder without you know
being able to talk to the dead person
many are unimpressed by hockey canada's
ceos testifying he plans to keep his job
including another james survivor sheldon
kennedy i'm prepared to take on this
responsibility
for change within our game i believe
i've got the experience to do it the
people who are making these
recommendations for change or promising
this change are the same people who
weren't worrying about making these
changes years ago they're the same
people who have been in power for years
issues of abuse within canada's game
aren't limited to hockey canada canadian
hockey league executives also testified
wednesday i would say since the
mid-2000s
the leagues are really focused on trying
to stamp out that behavior former nhl
player daniel carsillo takes issue with
that as one of the plaintiffs in a class
action against the chl writing in a
statement i disagree i believe that
there is a culture of hazing and abuse
in the chl systemic failures continue to
occur in protecting the children and
young people who play in the chl
while gail huley is most frustrated
hockey canada claims it wants to change
but doesn't want his help i was abused
by graham james and went through hockey
canada's process i would have thought
there would be a place for me with
hockey canada to help them do better
and i can't get my phone calls answered
he fears hockey canada is only focused
on doing the right thing so long as the
right thing keeps people in their
positions of power
abigail bieben global news ottawa
we're back from quebec city in just a
moment
we heard earlier about the push to
rescind the doctrine of discovery i
spoke with a mohawk human rights leader
about the doctrine and the pope's visit
uh mr kenneth dear thank you so much for
joining us here so we're in the the
final hours of this trip now he'll leave
quebec city tomorrow then head north
what do you make of what you've seen and
heard so far first of all
it's good that the pope came he came
here and to address the indigenous
peoples i think that that's always
significant he made a very good speech
his apology was was pretty good it could
have been better i i i
know they he still hasn't taken
responsibility for the to put a whole
church and it keeps blaming uh
individuals or groups you know and and
really it's this institution of the
church that that contributed to the
residential school uh abuse and and they
haven't acknowledged that so we're a
little disappointed in in that so but
you know time is uh still uh coming
we're not we're not stopping here and
one of the most common frames certainly
i've heard from people is that this is
you know they appreciate the words the
apology but they would also like to see
some action uh what would you like to
see on that well first of all our
delegation came here the hood nashony
external relations committee we came
here
not to ask for an apology for for years
now we've been on a campaign to get the
vatican to revoke
the people bulls that make up the
doctrine of discovery and uh because
these papal bulls is the basis of how
states have uh
claimed sovereignty over indigenous
lands and
and we need the pope to to clarify
change history because states still
today use the the doctor of discovery in
court cases uh against indigenous
peoples i gather you met the pope in
person in i think 2016. what are your
impressions of him
and and i guess his sincerity the way
he's handled all the pope
francis as an individual is a sincere
person but he also represents the
institution i think the words that he
use in uh in rome uh last spring i think
those were the lawyers that were talking
you know i think what he what you heard
uh here is more of pope francis a little
less of the lawyers however it's still
there they you know they still won't uh
the church itself as institution isn't
taking responsibility and that's the
lawyers talking you know so but it's it
was a step forward it was getting a
little bit closer and a little more
sincere and i think you could see a
little bit more into the into the heart
of pope francis how would you summarize
the way this trip has gone and the way
you know the indigenous people of this
country have responded to it there's a
wide range of reaction there are some
people who are ecstatic that he's here
and and they appreciate his uh his words
and his apology and there's other people
on the opposite end would uh the pope
can't possibly say anything that would
satisfy them and shows the depth of the
anger and and the mistrust over over 500
years uh uh that is really ingrained in
uh in in in our peoples about the effect
of the church on our people and how do
we move forward from this i mean what
happens after the apology the
replication of the papal bulls is a good
step would be a great step uh because
it's there's just so much uh
uh uh
damage that's been done to indigenous
sovereignty and self-determination and
also their spirituality that was taken
away from us an apology is just words
you know an apology doesn't mean
anything unless there's action uh onto
it many indigenous peoples uh the word
apology doesn't exist in their language
and it's it's what you're supposed to do
is make things right and that's what
we're trying to do is to make things
right as much as we can uh today and
into the future
kenneth dear thank you so much for your
very appreciate it
and that is global national for this
thursday good night from quebec city